in an unprecedented judgment from the
highest court in the land Prime Minister
has been found to have acted unlawfully
when he asked the Queen to suspend
Parliament pause to unpack that
prorogation never happened
Parliament has returned the rule of law
has been restored
this is constitutional and political
dynamite whatever happens next vote of
no-confidence general election second
vote caretaker p.m. is anyone's guess
and the only certainty is yet more
turmoil and confusion but the one thing
we can say for sure is this the Supreme
Court has unanimously ruled that
Parliament is sovereign over the crown
and the government whatever your
persuasion left or right leave will
remain this week has been a good one for
our parliamentary democracy I find it
really interesting when I saw the
verdict of the Supreme Court and I saw
who was celebrating and how they were
celebrating and how frequently the word
yes
democracy this a democracy be respected
was being used in those environments
because I found it directly
contradictory to what I would believe
democracy should have been applied to
which is back in 2016 which is the
referendum vote I find it hypocritical
when people are celebrating the verdict
which by the way you mentioned that it
was unanimous
I find that suspicious at best that you
can have such a complicated
unprecedented situation and unanimously
all of them 11 nil so as I find that
slightly well I think it's slightly
suspicious and I would question whether
or not either say well this is a deeply
complex situation where you've had
contradictory and I will tell him what I
think what I think three judges found it
for the prorogation you've got three who
are completely wrong Michele yeah you've
had multiple court's ruling in different
ways you've had different rumors had
contradictory rulers so this is very
clearly a calm
flex issue but yet apparently it's so
clear that all eleven judges rule the
same way unless we English ones were
wrong remember the defense was put up by
the government was pathetic they didn't
put any information to that cause enough
to sway the English Court yep in the
English and I'm not in P nglish I know
the judge's decision who spec knew I was
getting to go through some people they
own you will get end up at the Supreme
Court but the truth is the government's
defense of their position was pathetic
now what the question I ask is why why
did they not make a decent case for
themselves question to you - because you
think that the 11th Supreme Court
justices were wrong no no way I mean
would you be happy if that judgment had
gone the other way and the toys lost a
general election and Corbin then
prorogued Parliament for another for
let's say a year while he may be closed
down private school no way quickly I
didn't say it was wrong I said it was
suspicious that all 11 seem to have this
monumental moment of clarity about
something which previously exist on you
said it was fine great choice for the
Tory gooses thoughts for the Labour
gander no of course I wouldn't want to
see private schools closed down no no
I'm not talking about that you know the
general principle is who is sovereign
who is what is the highest authority in
the land come obviously the Supreme
Court currently but what needs to come
out of this as and when if and when is
we probably need a written constitution
that is what I think we are moving
towards all I would say is to pick up on
Greg's point in our previous
conversation just look at this from
outside the loathsome Westminster bubble
and you're watching this in Hull or
you're watching this in Sunderland or
you're watching this in Leicester and 11
judges for whom none of us vote I doubt
even we could name all their names they
sit and they decide to tell an unopposed
speaker to bring that MPs around 66% of
whom are seen not to carry out the
biggest mandate the country's ever seen
and you don't know let me finish please
and you don't see that as the I'm not
saying they're right but this is the
establishment sure I can see that I
should see that I think you guys need to
be really really
I mean I I didn't I didn't expect this
this to come into the discussion I mean
let me fit this I don't say ma'am I'm
uneasy about the judgment but actually
to for us to sit here and say actually
we know we're a bit smarter than these
eleven people said oh my you know all my
lecturers for example I mean I'm a
chemist all my lecturers agree that
Newton's laws of motion are basically
right does that because somebody does
that make it a conspiracy or is it not
they're asked to interpret they're asked
to interpret the Constitution and it
might be that actually for people who
actually know about the Constitution the
answer is straightforward so let's not
get into is there a conspiracy by
talking about whether they can we just
remind everybody that what actually
happened was that leader of an executive
government on a mandate of 90,000 Tory
members on that authority decided to
suspend a parliament of 560 elected MPs
during the most difficult and
constitutionally complicated period of
this country's modern history Greg well
I thought I'm when you looked at what
happened I just thought if I'm your
point if this had gone the other way
what we basic explain well if the judges
had found then that means any Prime
Minister the mopane Parliament anytime
they want no no has applied only done so
for four we have we have a constitution
based on on tradition and convention now
you're probably right Nick is the time
to start writing it down and say we
can't do that anymore because it gives
perhaps gives too much interpretation to
the to the judges
but I mean all they said was the reasons
you have given to do it for this
provocation
are not valid we're not saying we're not
we're not even either Michele are
implying bias or any inappropriate
improper behavior it's just puzzling
well this is worth suspicious me quite I
find it bizarre that you would reference
my intellect or perceived intellect in
this conversation interpreted what I was
saying is that somehow I believe I'm
more intellectual than this High Court
judge I find that really bizarre because
that I would never that would make me
smell all stupid what I am saying is I
just don't think the five of us are
qualified you know ii guess eleven
supremely court judge can I just make my
point actually which is that actually I
am sympathetic to the point of view that
I'm worried about this judgement because
personally I'm not sure that I want
lawyers deciding on what I think is
essentially a political matter I'm not
going to argue about whether they are
maybe in terms of constitutional right
Liam I'm just going to say I think that
that the what in technical terms you'd
call the competence of the court it's
now being expanded into a place where I
don't think anybody thought it would be
when it was set up the reason the judges
have had to stick their oar in is
because parliamentary sovereignty has
been eroded since the referendum result
and we've had to hear from one woman
Gina Miller who was had - she has had to
establish the principle that Parliament
is sovereign not once but twice since
referendum he was out first that
Parliament had to have a say on the deal
secondly that Parliament could not be
probed so let's hear from Gina Miller
it doesn't really matter who is prime
minister the office of Prime Minister
cannot decide to abuse their power and
close down Parliament our elected
representatives if that Parliament is
disagreeing with them if we had lost our
case if I'd lost the case then the
precedent would have stood that a prime
minister could just close down
parliament for five weeks and that is
not right our parliamentarians are there
to represent us it really is important
to understand that this case is much
much bigger than brexit it is about a
prime minister
using his power and actually giving the
Queen illegal advice Gino Miller not an
anti brexit activists not a pro remain
campaigner simply standing up for the
rule of law and due process of giving
judges powers that they shouldn't have
possible